Hey guys. So I probably should've made this video...
...before I went mixing in apples for about three weeks.
But the reason I haven't posted in a while is because,...
...well, there's actually three reasons why.
The first reason is because I recently just got back from Singapore and Malaysia...
...because I had a couple of shows.
It looked something like this.
The second reason is pretty obvious.
I'm sure you guys can hear it but I got pretty sick on that trip.
And it looks something like this.
And finally, last but not least,...
...the third reason is because well, I'm filming a movie!
Listen to my voice.
Let me do another take.
The last reason is because I'm filming a movie,...
...since you couldn't understand what I just said.
That's right, I'm a freaking mainstream Hollywood movie star now.
Well I mean, I'm not exactly the star of the film...
...so I guess you can't really call me a movie star.
And it's not exactly mainstream because it's an independent film.
And it's not even shot in Hollywood.
It's shot in Downtown LA.
But it's still a real movie, okay.
And I'm still a real movie star, okay.
I had so many lines, it looked just like this.
No buttons, guess they really don't want us to leave.
Who'd wanna leave?
I'm a movie star.